- Le va-et-vient est constant
à l'Hôpital de Montréal
pour enfants.
Des familles viennent ici
en dernier recours. Le taux
d'occupati202020202020202020202e
difficile depuis plusieurs
semaines.
- Il n'y a pas de médecin nulle
part
appellerait Info-Santé,
on attend longtemps.
ANDRÉ FORTIN, porte-parole
opposition officielle en santé
des témoignages de citoyens
qui se disent tout simplem
incapables d'avoir accès
à des soins de santé.
compte faire, le ministre de la
Santé rappelle que desesesures
ont déjà été mises en place.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
- Le 811 fonctionne très bien,
mais on manque de personnel
pour répondre au téléphone,
- La ligne pédiatrique 811 a été
mise à disposition des parents
d'enfants malades le mois
dernier pour désengorg
les urgences, mais les délais
pour parler à une infirmière
s'allongent.
Dre ARIANE MURRAY, médecédédédél
- Ça peut aller, tu sais,
probablement jusqu'à 1 h 30,
peut-être même les deux heures.
Il y a d'autreststststststststsé
et donc, c'est moins long.
- On pourrait prendre jusqu'à
5000 infirmières pour répondre
- Ce souhait exprimé par
Christian Dubé est irréaliste,
juge la présidente de prprprprpQ
- Il y a aux alentours justement
de 550 et 600 personnes
qui travaillent actuellement
Alors là, on dit qu'on veut
ajouter ça j 5 5 5 5 5000.
Où on va les trouver?
- Recruter assez d'infirmières
un objectif ambitieux.
- On nous dit qu'il
environ 5000 professionnels
en soins dans le réseau
- Ça fait quand même 15 ans
que je pratiqu
honnêtement, j'ai jamais vu
ça un automne aussi achalandé.
prévient que la situation dans
les hôpitaux du Qutetetetetera
difficile dans les prochaines
semaines.
Il presse lesononononononononoe
la COVID et l'influenza
et demandetstststststs de garder
les jeunes à la maison s'ils ont
des symptômes. Déjà près de